The last time I got ginger ale,
it was flat, and it was all around just a disappointing experience.
And since I was craving one,
I knew that as soon as I got home,
I had to just make myself one.
I started by peeling all of my ginger and slicing it into pieces.
I prefer doing this over grating it.
I transferred it over to a bowl
and got started on making a simple syrup by combining water and sugar.
Let that warm up until the sugar dissolved
before adding in all of my ginger and returning it to the heat.
I let it come to a boil
and then reduce that to a simmer and let that go for about 15 minutes
and then let it sit for another 30.
Once it was done steeping,
I strained it through a fine mesh strainer
and transferred it over to a smaller container
so that I could cool down in the fridge for about 45 minutes.
And that's all I had to do.
I filled my glass with some ice,
the syrup, topped it with some soda water,
and I always need to have my ginger ales with a fresh squeeze of lime,
so that's exactly what I did,
and this was exactly why I was craving. And it was heavenly.